我现在一个特别明白就是关于我小孩小朋友马上读小学的问题，
想请请你给给点建议吧，
那你说啊，
你是啥情况啊？
呃，
那我先说说我的，
简单说一下我家庭情况嘛，
我说是一个非常普通的家庭嘛，
然后之前之前是在工地上开挖机的，
然后一个月有七八千的收入，
然后说实话小时候家里比较穷嘛，
然后那时候就花手有点大手大脚的，
然后甚至还有点负债，
然后后面因为一点事情，
然后还赔了十几万，
所以刚开始跟我老婆在一起那几年过得有点惨，
然后然后这几年就跟我老婆出来开一个小饭店，
刚刚好，
今年差不多把债全部还完了，
然后这个小朋友明年马上要读小学了，
因为我们这个小饭店是在一个乡镇上面的嘛，
所以教育资源可能有点差，
我心想是要给他换一个好一点的城市，
给他一个好一点的教育资源，
因为我们这一个小朋友嘛，
然后我妈妈的建议是把小朋友送回老家，
让我妈妈帮我带，
那我们继续在这里干，
然后我老婆的想法是，
我们现在把这个店转完了，
然后要妈。
回老家的市里面，
然后打工嘛，
我先打工，
然后自己带着，
或者找一个好一点差不多一点的城市，
然后先打工自己带着，
然后我自己的想法是偏向，
偏向于我老婆后面的想法就是找个城市打工，
然后自己带，
然后我是我的想法是有点不是很想回家，
我感觉你和你老婆这个想法是对的啊，
小孩子他跟在父母身边和跟在爷爷奶奶身边那种感受是不一样的，
尤其是小孩子本身现在一直也是跟在你们身边的。
对，
因为很这重要对，
他跟着爸爸妈妈在身边和跟着爷爷奶奶在身边，
他那种安全感，
幸福感，
他是不一样的。
嗯，
他马上要读小学了，
对，
就是明年九月份要开始，
他在读小学这个过程当中，
反正实话实说啊，
有的时候在学校里面，
比如说遇到什么心事啊，
遇到谁欺负他呀，
遇到怎么怎么怎么样，
他如果是跟爷爷奶奶在一起，
他心里的那种支撑和跟爸爸妈妈在一起，
心里的那种支撑是不一样的，
嗯，
如果你和你的老婆现在又没有负债了是吧，
没有什么太大的经济压力了，
而且你和你老婆两个人都是双职工，
都能够工作的，
这个情况下，
也有这个能力，
能把孩子带在身边的情况下，
而且人家已经读小学了，
读小学了也不用你天天24小时都照看他了，
他白天他去上学去了，
就是晚上的时候接一下回来的时候跟你们生活在一起是吧，
不是的，
我个人啊，
我觉得就是爸爸妈妈如果不是万不得已，
实在没办法，
都一定是把孩子带在自己的身边，
是的，
因为我我们我们两个也是这样想的。
然后就是有一点，
要不要回老家的市里面，
还是说在外面找个地方比较好一点的城市去工作呢？
回老家的市里面的生活成本能降低吗？
就比如说是不是老家市里面已经有住的地方吗？
就不用住？
租房子了还是干嘛的也没有吧，
就是诶都是要从头开始啊，
都是要从头开始啊，
对这个事情啊，
我个人的感觉还是要权衡一下，
第一权衡一下你们两口子干的这个事儿是什么事儿，
在哪里能够挣钱更多，
这是第一，
第二的话，
也要去考虑一下当地的生活成本是不是很高，
我说句实在话啊，
就举个例子，
像我们团队有一个小伙伴，
就假设他如果在一线城市，
他假设啊说他呃，
年薪呃，
他那个呃，
月薪是1万块钱的话，
和他在我这个惠州这个地方月薪1万块钱完全是不同的概念，
因为他在一线城市，
他1万块钱的月薪的话，
他最起码得花3000块钱，
租房子最起码得花1000块钱，
通勤还得花各种各样的，
嗯，
就是在一线城市吧，
你偶尔你看个电影，
跟女朋友看个电影，
或者干嘛干嘛的，
消费水平都很高，
他在一线城市，
他一个月收入1万块钱，
他是攒不下来钱的，
但是他在我惠州这个地方的话，
他一个月1万块钱的话，
他可能能攒下来7000块钱，
为什么？
因为租房子只需要1000多。
啊，
他没有通行的成本，
就这意思，
所以你要问我说在哪里的话，
你看要权衡它的收入和成本，
算出来你一年能攒多少钱，
嗯嗯嗯，
也是吧，
可是现在还是点有点苦恼，
不知道回去还是不回去，
然后回去的话，
家里面有点麻烦事特别多，
然后一做有点不不是很想回去哦，
如果说家里面很多人际关系是你不不愿意面对的，
不想去结交的，
那你可以可以走远一点，
是就这意思啊，
好的好的，
来麻烦你了啊，
啊，
没事，
谢谢你啊，
拜拜，
我感觉作为一个父亲啊，
现在为孩子将来到底是留在哪里读书啊，
在哪里生活啊，
还愿意花钱来问一个像我这样的一个陌生人啊，
我感觉这父亲就是挺好的了，
挺靠谱的了，
你们觉得呢，
可能是干这个工作时间长了之后，
我对于丈夫和父亲这个角色的要求啊，
就是我感觉她有这个心，
对自己的孩子在打算，
将来再考虑，
为自己孩子再上心，
我就觉得挺好的了，
挺好的了，
可以了，
很好。